in this Beijing showroom AI products
made by one of China's largest
technology firms are proudly on display
including this image generator just
input instructions in Chinese and it can
create almost anything provided the
keywords don't contravene any censorship
laws
Baidu has invested and worked on AI for
more than 10 years and were the first
company to start artificial intelligence
research and development in China
this week the search engine company says
its generative AI chat bot its answer to
chat GPT is ready for its full launch
pending government approval
regulating AI is a priority for Beijing
new laws came into effect in January
Banning the use of AI to create and
share false information
and per draft regulations released in
April companies will need to ensure the
output of AI systems reflect socialist
values and do not undermine state power
or encourage violence or discrimination
China is quite ahead in terms of
Regulation and it's actually proposing
some of the strongest possible
regulation that we've heard from any
possible country this week as G7 leaders
met in Japan they agreed AI development
should be in line with their shared
democratic values
experts say governments are grappling
with the challenge of regulating a space
developing at such a rapid pace
in terms of which countries are leading
the way well it's very clear that Europe
and in some respects just behind China
are certainly leading the way that other
countries like the United States are
only just beginning to address the
concerns the potential harms that had
come from these Technologies
there's great interest in AI products
from Chinese consumers thousands came to
this commercial exhibition to see a
range of products
for most trying out such technology is
still a novelty
almost 500 exhibitors are here at this
artificial intelligence conference in
Tianjin showcasing some of their
developments in generative AI virtual
reality Robotics and more
this robot trained in classical Chinese
calligraphy was a particular hit
but experts say interactions in the
future likely won't be so fleeting as AI
becomes more integrated into daily life
Jessica Washington Al Jazeera Tianjin
China